yo the night that you battled freeway he
they were on Hot 97 that night or
something yeah earlier that night yeah
she started it and then Swiss was like I
got because obviously freeways from
Philly you're from Philly so that
happened at a recording studio yeah so
did you pull up knowing y'all were gonna
battle and did he know you guys were
gonna battle no I was already in the
studio and I went to McDonald's when I
heard them on the radio rapping and
talking about they want to battle and
anybody could get it so they wasn't
talking about me but I felt like they
was right so when I got back to the
studio I told Swiss about it and he like
I don't matter Jay-Z coming to a studio
tonight anyway so I'm just sitting
around doing Jay-Z got there he
introduced them to me introduced me as
like him like the next one yeah and
Jay-Z took offense today like what you
ain't had my artist I got the hottest
[__] in that's how I started getting
competitive oh start talking he called
them up we called out peoples up next
thing you know the studio was crowded
and we battle